let's uh let let's start with um
uh i have a question before we get into
some of the charts here but my main
question for you is just uh
when you wake up every day
where do you go look at information and
like what is your process in the morning
to get a sense of here's where we're at
yeah great question um so
i don't have like a specific regimen
although i'm actually in the process of
writing that out because i think it's
important it's just something that i
haven't done just because honestly i've
just been lazy and doing it i kind of
kind of a general
process that i go through in my mind
first things first is i wake up i read a
couple newsletters that i'm subscribed
to
i'll go in and obviously check bitcoin's
price
uh see what's going on in the futures
market if i if i wake up early if i wake
up late and the stock market's already
trading uh hopefully i generally don't
wake up that late but um you know if i
do i'll just check what the stock
market's trading at if that'll check
features uh before 9 30. i'll just read
some you know headlines on like
marketwatch and some major kind of news
providers to see if maybe anything crazy
that's going to change the world
happened while i was sleeping
and then i'll go in and the first thing
i'll check bitcoin specifically aside
from prices i'll just go and start
looking at derivatives data
so i'll look at several things i'll look
at you know funding um or lately i've
just been looking at the premium or
discount of spot and perps look at what
open interest is doing
uh and then as well also go and look at
the order books see if any orders came
in and are out overnight
especially
across several different exchanges and
look for confluence and some of that
behavior across
different exchanges
um and then last thing i'll i'll go in
and just look at you know
[Music]
some entrained stuff overnight generally
speaking that doesn't fluctuate much
so like glass node for example their
data updates are like 8 30 every night
um eastern time because i'm on the east
coast so you know overnight there's not
like too much actually changing there
but sometimes in like some hourly things
like soaper or exchange flows i'll look
at some of those things on like an
hourly basis but uh that's that's pretty
much uh the high level and then the
other one i guess to throw in is just
checking twitter and seeing if there's
any you know crypto native uh news
events that came out overnight
you know sometimes you can sometimes you
can gauge what happened with price just
by doing a quick scroll through your
feed overnight
yeah you just gotta check sentiment real
quick um
but yeah i mean just like looking
through to see if any like you know
twitter personalities like you or
whoever have posted any kind of big news
events crypto related as well and then
that's pretty much it yeah it's it's not
you know i i need to create a checklist
for myself because i know that's
something that you know
like more sophisticated traders do is
they have kind of a regimen that they go
through like i talked to um abi fellman
from block tower and that's one of my
biggest takeaways from him was like not
just the information he was providing
but basically like uh you know how how
structured his mind was and
you know orientation to the market and
basically how organized uh his approach
was to the market and how consistent he
was staying with it one other thing i'm
thinking about starting to do is like
journaling so this is something that
several of the traders that i've talked
to in my podcast or just
privately do is you know just jot down
your thoughts every morning what your
thought process is your emotions at the
time how you're feeling and then you can
go back and kind of resort to that i
kind of do that with the newsletter but
it's on a weekly basis rather than a
daily basis so i might start doing that
on a daily basis but the newsletter um
you know i like that i can kind of go
back see where my thoughts were at the
time
you know kind of look for patterns and
different metrics or price action as
well and kind of see what my thought
process was at the time and that really
kind of helps you uh you know master
your emotions i'm definitely not a
master of my emotions now but
i like to say that uh you know i'm
getting better in that sense and you
know journaling and writing down your
thoughts even on a weekly basis like
i've been doing for the last year so
it's definitely been helpful
yeah it's super interesting um when you
start to think about uh
the clarity of thought the information
inputs but then also going back and
revisiting hey what was i thinking then
how uh one of the big things is uh for
me uh writing um is you know it's not a
private journal but writing every
morning uh allows me to go back and and
you know kind of be intellectually
honest about like hey what did i get
right what did i get wrong um so that
makes a lot of sense yeah and and the
other thing as well is like lately i've
been doing these
like educational videos on my youtube
channel or not to show the youtube
channel but um also like on twitter i'll
do these little threads and where i'm
going with this is not to tell people to
go to go look at them but just that per
like selfishly by going through and
doing this i have to go back to the
basics a lot of times and either you
know i'll have to revisit things
that maybe you know i i forgot about or
as well you know maybe by going through
that process i you know come to new
understandings by like revisiting you
know the fundamentals of things so
like overall just that again like as you
just said that process of writing as
well as like creating educational
content and going back to the basics and
like solidifying that
i find that like super beneficial for
sure
yeah and you find holes in your thinking
and all that kind of thing so
completely agree all right let's get
into uh the market itself uh you
recently described it as a trendless
chop explain what that means uh in terms
of what's happening right now
yeah so this first section is actually
written by our equity analyst blake
davis i think he always does a great job
but i think he's generally just talking
about broader markets um you know not
really seeing any trend i'll do that
like moving averages which is price
structure in general
just kind of just seeing like you know
as you said trendless trendless chop um
i think that's that's also pretty true
for for bitcoin as well but definitely
with
uh all kind of the macro uncertainty and
you know we've got everything going on
with like russia and ukraine
i think that's kind of translating into
price action and drifi but uh yeah
that's personally that's definitely not
my area expertise so you'd have to ask
blake exactly what he meant there and do
you think that that is uh
the same thing for bitcoin as like the
broader market right now
in in what sense you're saying like the
trendlessness or just trendless chop
um yeah i think
i think you know we've been in a
downtrend for three months
and um you know as we get further into
this i'll highlight a couple levels that
i think we kind of need to get back
above just you know definitively say
that we've kind of broken out of this
downtrend
um you know we've we've seen some you
know promising um you know behavior over
the last like two weeks but i still
think we need to get back above 47k
that's kind of my uh line in the stand
from like a high time frame perspective
i think there's a lot of uh confluence
there i'll be that with on chain as well
as price structure and if we can reclaim
that uh i think you know we've regained
uh momentum so like
i think i think there's in this market
there's like value buyers and there's
momentum buyers and this is a mental
framework that i stole from abby feldman
at block tower but i really like it
and i think
value is kind of in the low 30s and
momentum is getting back above that 47k
area
and so you know for people that are you
know kind of just looking to get in the
market on like high time frame momentum
i think that's kind of the area that you
should be watching
makes sense um i saw that you were
tweeting about and you included in the
newsletter uh hash rate and just kind of
the explosive recovery uh of hashrate uh
talk to me about why is that so telling
to you
yeah i think you know it's it's really
incredible this is one of the i think
biggest accomplishments of the bitcoin
network uh maybe i mean in recent
history but maybe in all of its history
reasoning is because you had one of the
you know largest global superpowers
being china banning bitcoin mining we
saw a massive exodus of hash rate coming
off the network as you can see in the
chart between may and july
during that time
i think this was actually you know a
fundamentally
bullish event in the moment because now
all of a sudden you have all this hash
that's moving out of china and that was
one of the the big you know
fuds if you will that you would hear
from people oh all the mining you know
hash power is concentrated in china
so now that you know that argument is
gone and with that as well over the last
few months we've seen a complete
recovery of that hash back on coming
back online
and what this basically means is that
all these machines have been migrated
across the world in a completely
decentralized way both the physical and
human capital around the world and
replugged in
and just you know in several months
we've seen that not only come back to
where it was prior to the prior to the
drop but actually we've seen this
continue to ramp up over the last few
weeks we've seen a really aggressive
move up in hash
and here at block where we continue to
be very bullish on on hash we think over
the next year we'll continue to see this
this this trend as more just entities in
general uh continue to be interested in
getting involved with bitcoin mining
um you know i think yeah again it's just
it just kind of goes to show you know
the resiliency of the bitcoin network uh
and currently the network's more secure
than ever as as hash continues to grind
out yeah talk to me about the uh kind of
derivatives market obviously there's
been a lot of activity there as we go
sideways that looks like it's kind of
lining up with a lot of the price
movements
yeah so um on screen i think we have the
the bitcoin price chart with the
perpetual basis indicator below so first
we could just like talk about price
briefly
so again i think kind of the low 30s or
a value area for btc
i think 47k is that area that btc needs
to reclaim to kind of establish momentum
especially from a high time frame
perspective
these are some of just the four kind of
major price levels that i think we've
got for bitcoin on a daily level
um i think we're currently sitting at
an important kind of pivot level if we
go back and look at where 41 to i'm
sorry 40 to 41k
we've seen a lot of kind of reaction
from price from that throughout the
throughout the last year so that
basically defined the whole summer range
we bounced off that at the end of
september
bounced off that in january before
finally breaking through
and as well you know recently we've seen
some reaction of the last day or two
with this price area
i think if bitcoin can flip this 39 to
40 area then you're probably looking at
continuation back up to 47 at a minimum
if we get back below that well then once
below then 40k becomes expensive so i
think if you start closing below 40 you
probably see btc retrace back to these
local lows but for the next day or so
i'm just kind of watching to see this
reaction in this area i think you know
if if it can't hold then that's quite
bullish probably so yeah you know move
back up to 40 47 k
if we start closing below probably see a
retracement back to those local lows so
you know with this stuff you know it's
always probabilities it's always
speaking in if then statements right no
one knows exactly what's going to happen
we just identify the setups and we set
up you know probabilistic statements
based on that information and so with
that being said again i think if we can
hold this area see continuation to 47k
if we start closing below the 40k area i
think we probably see a retracement back
to those local lows um on to the
derivative stuff
so at the bottom you'll see this
indicator called perpetual basis
so if anyone's been listening to me on
this channel or just in general
and pomp as well as when you've when
you've gone through the newsletter
you've probably talked about this as
well is the funding rate
this is something that i still think is
extremely important
but i've i've kind of veered away from
looking at funding and instead of looked
at something called premium or discount
so why why do i say that
when we're looking at funding what we're
essentially trying to gauge is the
difference in activity between spot and
perps
and so with that you know the funding
rate is calculated differently on every
single exchange
some way you know different exchanges uh
more than others as well as just the you
know the math behind the actual funding
rate is different on others
and so with that being said you know
when you kind of just think of like from
first principles like what are you
trying to gauge here well you're trying
to gauge the difference in activity
again between spot and purpose so
instead of looking at funding why not
just look at the raw difference in price
between spot and perps and so that's
what the premium discount is
and so that's what i've started to look
at recently
and that's that's what you see on the
bottom is that whenever whenever you see
the indicator getting into the green
area it means that perps are trading
below spot so you basically take a you
know weighted average of all the perps
based on open interest and then you take
the weighted average of all
spot btc exchanges based on volume
compare the two and you get the
difference which is either a premium or
discount based on whether perps are
trading above or below spot
and so you want to be buying btc or
averaging into btc when spot is trading
at a premium to perps
and then conversely you know you
probably want to be a little cautious
whenever perps are trading at a premium
to spot especially when you see a
prolonged regime of that
with that being said
uh i think you can look at two things
very similar to what i always say about
funding um so first of all you know we
can look at discrepancies between you
know the indicator and price and second
of all we can look for regimes or
prolonged period of times where we're in
periods of time where we're in you know
one area whether it be a premium or
discount
and so the kind of general rule of thumb
that i personally see with this is that
the longer and the more aggressive a
trend is in the indicator the more
likely the move is likely to be once it
once it reverts so an example of this
would uh be going back to like early
2021 we had a prolonged premium of perps
over spot
i think funding was at like 250 percent
apr something absolutely crazy like that
um and so for months we persisted with
this with this premium and so what
that's basically telling you like from
the psychological aspect is that you
know leveraged traders are just getting
you know basically conditioned
to keep leverage longing all dips right
because they just get bailed out by
these spot buyers throughout all of
early 2021 a lot of that was you know
grayscale coming in and buying btc
consistently
as you have a you know prolonged
conditioning of that behavior once the
trend finally changes you see a really
massive move to the other direction it's
almost like a pendulum swinging right
when you get people really conditioned
to one behavior then once that once the
underlying trend changes they're so used
to participating in that one behavior
that's difficult to all of a sudden
change your bias and adjust to the new
trend
and so so basically i think that's kind
of the psychological aspect that's kind
of baked into that big move you know
wipe out in in may um we had to move
down to about 40k and also when you had
a bunch of leveraged buyers step in
um and then that caused that final flush
down to 30 because basically everyone
was trying to catch a falling knife when
price had initially moved down to 40.
and so that's just an example of when
you have a longer regime of either you
know premium or discount i think the
more aggressive and the more prolonged
that regime is the larger the move is
once it reverts so you saw the same
thing at the end of
the end of summer 2021 or last year
you know initially
traders were cashing in by fading every
rally up to 40k and then towards the end
of the range they were cashing in by
fading every single rally up to 35k they
got extremely complacent and shorting
every single move up and so once that
that uh you know new regime finally came
we started to grind up off the lows with
that failed breakdown below 30. well
they were so conditioned of shorting
every single pump that that behavior
that you know conditioning of behavior
allows for more fuel once that trend
finally reverses and so with that being
said
i think currently we're in a pretty
prolonged regime of spot premium over
perps and as well what you what you also
want to see is that going further
negative so if you'll see when we swept
the kind of 33k lows
we actually saw this going further
negative and further negative so that's
another thing you can look for basically
whenever you go back and see
uh the discount going you know further
negative and when i'm saying discount
i'm saying discount of perps below spot
or
premium of spot above perps it's either
way you wanna it's thing you know two of
the same thing um you know whenever you
see that going further in one direction
in this case you know further negative
um that's another that's another you
know way you can look at this as well as
you're seeing the trend get more and
more aggressive people are becoming more
and more conditioned for one one type of
behavior uh but overall though you know
we're in this prolonged regime of of uh
spot premium which is just something
that even at a minimum you can just
consider as kind of a backdrop for other
market behavior and put that into
context with it
but you aren't seeing any type of froth
and derivatives you're actually seeing
the opposite of spot is leading the
market currently
got it and so if we take a look one of
the things that um
i'm not as familiar with but sounds like
you've been doing some work on is
these order books as well right you
talked a little bit about kind of the
spot buyer stepping in and we start to
look at the visualizations of uh these
order books it seems to tell a very
similar story
is that a fair way to look at this
sure so kind of going back to that like
value momentum mental framework so
again i think 47k is the area to reclaim
momentum i think for value buyers that
that area is kind of 30 to 35k
and so the reasoning behind that is kind
of several reasons um and so i'll tie
this up to the order thing in a second
um so first of all just like price
structure so if we go back and look btc
is basically just in a very large range
between 30 and 60k and 30 to 35k is the
bottom of that range that's the bottom
extreme of that range
second thing is this chart here which is
looking at order books
in particular i like to look at the spot
order books over the futures order books
just because you tend to see less
spoofing in the in the spot order books
you do see some but not not as much at
least from what what you know my
experience in monitoring them
and in particular i have coinbase on on
the screen currently uh but across you
know kind of across the board
based off of several you know major spot
exchanges you're seeing kind of
confluence as well the same thing of
just spots and spots
bids in that kind of 30k area low 30s
area
and so to me that's showing that you
know there's large buyers that are kind
of seeing that as an area of interest as
an area of value in their minds
the third the third thing that makes me
think that kind of the low 30s is a
value area is when we kind of go to the
next chart which is looking at whales
holdings
what's interesting is that you saw them
kind of uptick when we swept the low 30s
when we had that move down to the 30 to
33k
very similar to the massive uptick we
saw in wales holdings off the lows over
summer
and so to me that's showing you that
there's there's some entities or market
participants that are interested in
doing business in the low 30s especially
because as we've moved off the low 30s
out after the last
it was like two weeks ago that we swept
the low 30s we've seen their holdings
just kind of flat so you see in the on
the right hand side like on the very
right hand side you'll see an uptick
pretty substantial uptick as we move
down to that 33 34k area
we talked about the coinbase buyer that
had been stepping in at the time and we
also talked about this chart which was
whales holdings for moving up
you know since then we got to move up to
about 45k
but we haven't seen any fall through in
wales over the last two or three weeks
since we last spoke since then we've
just kind of seen their holdings flat
and so to me this is interesting because
it's showing you that you know large
large market participants or large
entities on on chain are interested in
adding to their holdings in the low 30s
but so far it doesn't look like they're
interested in doing business in the in
the low 40s
until proven otherwise but this just
kind of adds in confluence to the other
two factors that i mentioned price
structure and order books that it seems
like the low 30s are kind of an area of
value seen by larger market participants
what are whales doing
yeah so um that's basically the chart i
was just just pulling up so you know
they had been in a downtrend since
september
they kind of bought they bought the
whole way up from kind of the end of
2020 up to about you know february early
march of 2021
basically distributed
all the way down into the summer
re-accumulated at the summer lows bought
all the way up until about september and
then from then they had been
distributing up until call it you know
three weeks ago
they had bought kind of the 33 34k area
when we swept that area yep and again
since then when they just kind of kind
of been flat
and one of the things that's interesting
to me is whales i think a lot of times
are uh used as a proxy for experience
right
do you
agree with that or is that a little
misleading in that uh the folks with the
largest holdings may not actually be the
longest term holders or the most
experienced in the market
yeah i don't i don't yeah i don't
necessarily think so um it to me it
seems like based off of like historical
kind of data from you know on-chain
perspective
um you know it seems like whales are
more momentum buyers than than anything
uh we kind of you know following whale
behavior has you know generally uh
you know has generally been productive
um but they don't perfectly you know
time to the macro bottoms like they were
you know like buying extremely heavily
in like the end of the bottom of 2018
for example but we did see long-term
holder supply increasing at the bottom
of 2018. so i think there's just a bit
of a you know kind of nuance there and
like a bit of a distinguish between
wales doesn't necessarily always
translate to longer term market
participants these could just be you
know momentum buyers in the market i
think especially over when you look at
this data over the last kind of year or
so it kind of illustrates that as well
that you start to see whales kind of
buying momentum and then distributing
into that you know final push-up and
strength
got it and so uh you've got these charts
in here on the quarterlies um explain
what these two are are showing us
yeah so we're basically looking at the
spread between
spot and three month futures so you can
go you can buy spot
short the three-month future capture the
difference so this is you know when
everyone was talking about at the
beginning of the year the cash and carry
trade
where everyone learned about including
myself what contango meant when the
futures curve is trading at a positive
slope out to the future
and so like in early 2021 or kind of mid
2021 this got all the way up to 45
annualized which is absolutely insane um
and so i don't think we'll ever get back
up to those levels because i just think
the market is going to become more
efficient over time i think more capital
coming into the space that's going to
look to do these type of arbitrage
opportunities
maybe that will funnel into directional
btc positions
it's hard to kind of make that
speculative conclusion but i do think
over time you you'll never get back up
to those 40 45
like you know crazy uh euphoria levels
um i think i think though there's more
capital looking to kind of arb that away
as the market kind of becomes more
efficient with that being said though i
do still think um this is kind of a good
gauge for euphoria or depression in the
market just basically kind of what what
trader sentiment is
as we can see this got extremely low at
the bottom of at the bottom of summer
uh got pretty low at the end of
september as well and got fairly high
when we had that push up to 67k um so
you know just kind of follows price and
just basically is kind of a gauge for
what sentiment amongst derivatives
traders um this actually broke below
five percent
which means you know still more than
what a treasury is is gonna yield you
but um
but you know it's it's still relatively
low compared to where this has been over
the last uh year or two um historically
though just something to like keep an
eye out for um is whenever quarterly's
going to backwardation that's
historically been a great buy
opportunity so if you kind of go back
and back test whenever quarterlies have
gone into backwardation that's
that's been a a good opportunity for
kind of like a longer term horizon buy
and then like
kind of going off of that as well i have
this next chart
i literally just like threw this
together while i was making the
newsletter i was just like tinkering
around with it uh i think it's
interesting basically comparing the
seven day moving average of quarterlies
as well as the 14 day moving average of
quarterlies
these large spikes
um are basically when we like the seven
day moving average is trading
substantially below the the 14 day
and so that's kind of offered these
these good at least you know kind of
local local buy opportunities especially
when you see like crazy substantial
spikes like you know
at the end of september 2020 for example
and it's interesting um
some people say you like shouldn't like
draw trend lines on this stuff but i do
think it's interesting it almost looks
like this is kind of coiling up
uh we'll see i don't know i just i just
said you created this to be honest but i
think it's something to look in
for confidence with um you know if you
if you see core release this is the main
thing though if you see quarterlys go
backward that's almost always a great
buy opportunity though
let's jump ahead to the mayor multiple
which i think is a pretty simple uh uh
metric but one that has been uh pretty
accurate over uh time what are you
seeing here
yeah so in the letter this week from an
unchained perspective i try to just like
write this out for long-term investors
because that's really my kind of mental
approach right now
is i think there's so much going on with
macro and it's just you know very murky
times that i think
you know i'm not trying to do any
short-term trades currently i'm just
looking at this in a very broad sense
and with that i'm looking at some of
these kind of macro what we call macro
oscillators from an on-chain perspective
basically oscillators that track
historical bitcoin behavior for market
participants um and i think you know
these are best used
to i don't think there's certain values
that you can say oh this is a you know
this is the pico bottom and this is the
peak out top but i think you can look at
these things to basically gauge where's
the asymmetry
right so you probably want to de-risk
when the asymmetry
is you know to the downside and you
probably want to risk on a bit or you
know start averaging in when the
asymmetry is you know drastically to the
upside uh and currently looking at
several of these charts and the first of
first of which is is the mayor multiple
and there's three others that maybe
we'll we'll take a peek at uh i think
that's kind of the the point i was
trying to make in the newsletter this
week is that there's kind of confluence
across the board of
yeah not every single one of these
metrics although several of them are at
like very historical lows but you know
across the board they're not all at like
pico bottoms but they are you know in
the kind of the lower 25th you know
percent percentile of where they've
historically traded so
um generally speaking i just think
especially the low 30s as we said a few
weeks ago but generally you know uh
these areas are are good to kind of
average into btc and i think anyone
trying to time the the absolute bottom i
think that's kind of a fool's game
you know i think kind of averaging into
these these lower areas lower
extremities of these of these metrics is
probably a good idea and historically
has been the mayor multiple just
compares price to the 200-day moving
average
and so basically you know it shows you
where price is trading relative to what
the broader trend has been
uh and so as you'll see we're trading
near that kind of green line at the
bottom it's really kind of arbitrary
just showing you like where you know
where bitcoin is like historically kind
of bottomed out in a broad sense and uh
we are trading very close to that after
being below that when we swipe 33k still
very close to that
then again that's just kind of showing
you that the asymmetry is is not to the
downside in a broader sense in my mind
got it and then if we go ahead and we
take a look at uh dormancy flows i know
that this is something uh that you've
started to pay more and more attention
to it seems like we've seen uh tim rover
at fidelity he put out a whole piece on
this as well that i think uh either you
had some influence on or it seems like
he had uh been learning some stuff here
as well how uh how are you thinking
about dormancy right now
yes it's pretty cool to see dudes at
fidelity looking at unchained stuff and
hopefully hopefully we see more of that
but um
yeah so this this one out of all the
charts that i'm i'm looking at like
these broader oscillators this one
definitely got like the most engagement
on twitter because it looks the best
like let's just be honest um
and you know like when we look at this
it's at the fourth lowest value uh in
bitcoin's history you look at you know
2011 2012 2015 at the bottom of the bear
bottom of 2018 bear kova dump uh summer
of last year and now those are all the
times that we've seen this dip this low
so this is just again
showing you that kind of in a broader
sense i don't think that the asymmetry
is skewed to the downside versus the
potential upside and you know kind of a
six to nine month time horizon
this is basically comparing the usd
value of destruction relative to the 365
day or yearly moving average so it's
basically showing you the spending of
older coins relative to the yearly uh
kind of trend of that behavior and so at
this time you're seeing a decrease in
spending from those from those older
coins
got it and like when you start to look
at this if we go back to the summer of
2021. um
you and i spent a bunch of time talking
about uh just constant increase in the
eliquids circulating supply it feels
like we're kind of inching more and more
and more in that same kind of trend as
we were uh obviously there was a pretty
large you know price movement uh towards
the end of the summer and into q3
uh is your
at least directional thought process of
like that's kind of what we're seeing
happen it's happening slowly there's
like a grind but it's somewhat of a
repeat uh when we saw when bitcoin had
dropped down to the low 30 thousands or
so back in the summer 21.
yeah i think the big difference is the
following so
yes like supply dynamics look great from
an on-chain perspective and they have
for a month or two so probably sound
like a bit of a broken record in that
regard um when we look at you know again
a liquid supply we look at a metric like
this which is based off of coin days
destroyed showing you a decrease in
spending from all their coins uh
long-term holder supply
um hotter waves i mean several different
measures from an on-chain perspective
are all kind of showing confluence of
strong holding behavior and basically
that you know the the qualitative aspect
of of bitcoin's float looks strong but
of course that's one side of the
equation and so with that being said i
think like summer of last year's was a
bit different from now although liquid
supply and some of these other metrics
did look very similar you saw an
aggressive you know uh
aggressive trend of of holding behavior
in all those as well at the end of
summer 2021 i think the big difference
though was the macro backdrop right so
at the time you still had a dovish bed
and so basically from from 2020 all the
way up to the end of last year
every single time that on chain had
shown strong holding behavior that had
translated to price action and so people
were you know
i think like the peak of on-chain's
popularity was like the end of 2020
early 2021 because basically every
single time that you had you know supply
start to get constrained from an
on-chain perspective that translated to
price action but why because there was
constant demand because we had you know
the whole inflation hedge narrative
going extremely dovish fed just very
strong uh you know monetary and just
monetary conditions as a general macro
backdrop
for bitcoin and so with that being said
when you had that one you know the one
end of the equation cooking which was
the demand that was constantly steady
every time the supply end got
constrained you saw that translate to
price action um and so i think recently
over the last few months
yes and kind of since the end of
november yes we've have continued to see
um strong holding behavior but i think
the demand has been lackluster because
of the macro backdrop
and so with that being said i think the
way i kind of view this is the following
um i think lynn alden worded this well
that uh she she's we've talked a bit in
in the dms about this kind of exact
phenomena and basically that you know
you have the fuel laid out but you just
kind of need a spark to ignite that fuel
because the the float of bitcoin from an
unchained perspective looks very strong
again you're seeing you know uh highly
behavior coins moving to entities who
have a low spending history
but i think again that that demand is
the demand side of the equation is has
just kind of been been lackluster with
that being said though
you know i think um
over the next six to nine months uh you
know i think you will most likely see
that demand step back in once kind of uh
you know the uncertainty in the market
cools off in the legacy markets uh maybe
that just means that we need to get
through march after the pharmacy meeting
and and see you know what the fed
actually does and then people feel more
comfortable making decisions just
because nobody really knows exactly
there's still a lot of people that are
kind of think the you know the fed is
just draw on it uh jawboning some people
think that they're gonna raise rates six
seven times i'm not a macroeconomics
expert and i'm not going to lurk like i
am one so i don't have the answer for
you but i think once we clear that
uncertainty
or if we have some type of catalyst for
btc that would cause idiosyncratic or
unique flows into btc that would be
another potential catalyst of demand
and you know there's several potential
things for that there may be like an
over subscription to the el salvador
bond coming up or another country
following el salvador uh you know spot
etf surprise which i think that the
likelihood of that is low but several
different things that you can make a
case for a potential catalyst but if not
that catalyst then i think the other
thing that's gonna that's gonna be
needed to happen to kind of draw in that
demand would be kind of a decrease in
the macro uncertainty generally in
legacy markets yeah it makes a lot of
sense it gives us a lot to think about
last chart i want to go over is the
on-chain cost basis which uh
speaking of looking pretty uh anytime
people see kind of big swoops and drops
i think they say okay what's going on
here what uh what are you seeing here
yeah sure so this one was uh created by
dylan
uh basically what he did was compare the
the short term holder uh realized price
which is a been a historical level that
uh prices interact with from like a high
time frame perspective it's also
partially why i think 47k is such an
important value that short term holder
realized price which sits
right around 46 47k
um and then you look at long-term holder
realized price which is the same thing
it's the cost basis of long-term uh
holders on chain
and so then you just run a simple ratio
of the two and compare them and so
that's what this blue line is it's the
ratio of short-term holders and their
cost basis and long-term holders cost
basis
and it's very interesting to kind of see
how historically uh
like the psychology of how this has kind
of been embedded into the market
whenever your short-term holder realized
price goes below long term holder
realized price that's been like
historically a good buy opportunity
uh and the reasoning is just basically
because you have short term holders
capitulating or they age into long term
holders
and then at that time the long term
holders kind of set the floor at the
bottom of the bear and then conversely
whenever we reach the top extreme of
this of this oscillator we get above the
red area
um that's historically signal that
long-term holders are distributing very
heavily and so again i don't look at
these you know the red line and the
green line is like definitive values
they're just arbitrary numbers based off
of historical context but what i what i
do think again is interesting as as we
talked about is just looking at where's
the asymmetry right and again
like the other metrics uh that that we
just looked at as well as um
i know we're short on time but there's
two others as well um you know we're in
the bottom 25th per you know percentile
of of this metric as well and so with
that being said again just trying to
make that point that i think the
asymmetry isn't currently to the
downside with a six nine months kind of
time horizon
when you take a look uh and you just
zoom out
bullish
bearish
short-term concerned like how do you
think about short-term and long-term i
think long-term you and i both you know
very very bullish uh but how do you
think about the short-term uh and are
you trying to trade any of this are you
just saying hey you know
maybe there's some buying opportunities
in the future but but ultimately not
necessarily trading or what are you
doing
yeah um again so like i kind of
i'm kind of looking at this as the
following i think that you know it's
very murky with kind of the the backdrop
for btc
so i'm not making any like short-term
trades currently i'm actually just
averaging in um and if we go down to the
low 30s i'll averaging fairly heavily
again
you know i think that's again kind of a
value area and given a lot of these like
broader oscillators that are useful for
someone with a longer time horizon uh
six to nine months year plus time
horizon uh i i do think kind of these
these you know low 30 areas um
the overall kind of 30 to 40k area in
general will be seen as a value area you
know after a year your you know plus
time horizon especially after we clear
some of the things that we just talked
about um but yeah currently i'm not i'm
not making any any uh any trades i think
um
[Music]
sometimes it's it's as simple as just
looking at like what's the
what's the profile of potential downside
versus upside and again i think like
with the with the broader kind of uh
um you know time frame i think that
that's not to the downside at this time
yeah i think that's a
very measured sober view of the world i
love it um all right
i appreciate you taking the time to do
this you got any uh weekend plans
um yeah so tomorrow i find out uh about
which puppy i get so i'm getting a dog
oh
little puppy action what kind are you
getting do like do you have a specific
type and they just you just don't know
which one yet
yeah it's uh it's a golden doodle so
yeah they're a little fluffy they look
like teddy bears dude they're really
cute they're like how big did they get
so they so there's mini medium and then
there's standard and so i'm getting the
medium which is like 30 35 pounds
so yeah
whenever whenever i pick them up i'll
definitely have to have him on the show
we've never had a ranger on the show so
maybe we'll do like a ranger and your
dog do you have a name picked out yet no
not yet i feel like um you can
brainstorm in it a little bit but i feel
like
you gotta see the dog and then like
you'll you'll get a that's how it was
with my last two dogs at home yeah you
got it because this thing will be mine
personally but yeah you got to see it
and then you're like okay like you got
to feel out of his personality a little
bit well
don't don't tell anyone i named our
daughter before i ever met her
so you know
that's that's human that's the human
game with dogs i feel like it's
different you got to see that yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah for sure the uh okay
so when you name it satoshi we won't be
scared
i don't know i don't know about that man
no please don't do that please don't
save yourself the uh the the headache
later when uh when people were like of
course your dog is named satoshi like
here's here's a piece of advice my dad
gave me uh and i've heard him tell many
people who've had kids this he said the
whole key is to uh set your child up for
success like don't set your kid back a
step with their name uh i think a dog is
the same thing right is like you know
just have a name that everyone likes
yeah exactly yeah i feel you but yeah i
definitely have to have them on will
what'd you say don't name the dog will
so satoshi is out and will would be
weird too definitely definitely not if
you name it joe i won't tell them
yeah that's not happening
we'll see i don't know man it's if you
get ideas if you got ideas text me
we'll brainstorm a little bit but our
girlfriend's on it though she's
she's been like texting me names every
two seconds for the last like
two weeks so i should probably come up
with something if i don't so yeah well
listen here here's uh here's how
girlfriends usually work is if you don't
come up with the name quickly she's
definitely going to come up with the
name so if you want any saying that you
better hurry up
yeah i need to i need to get out and
stop looking at the charts brainstorming
all right buddy i appreciate you coming
on uh we will do this again uh in a week
or two and uh uh best of luck out there
to everyone but i i think that uh the
data's pretty clear what do we have 585
now
will by the way are you 19 or are you 20
i'm 19. i got about uh i was gonna say
your birthday's coming up soon right in
the next two months two months all right
all right
then everyone always says you've been 19
for 10 years no listen listen listen
listen as somebody who's 33
stay 19 as long as you can if you can
slow down time let me know what the
secret is that's the uh that's the key
it's just stay young forever 20 blows
because then i got a whole another year
before i can drink but
we'll see do i do i get facial hair and
and legal drinking before the next bull
run wasn't
i think that uh uh i think that you're
fine
people are like yeah it just felt like
10 years because of all the volatility
but yeah exactly i think you're good
it's like it's like uh that movie
interstellar you know you're on the
planet for one day it's like a year that
that's how it is in this market man but
all right brother well thanks again for
having me on i'll talk to you soon all
right later buddy all right see man